un week-end pour découvrir les
exploitations agricoles de la région les
producteurs du réseau bienvenue à la
ferme ou alors jusqu'à ce soir une
opération pour mieux connaître leur
travail elles étaient organisées un peu
partout en france une trentaine de
familles participent dans le loiret une
vingtaine en touraine thomas diego badia
et delphine landais sont allés à la
ferme de la rue ries a remis en
indre-et-loire chez un éleveur philippe
braud sion l'écoutent
donc l'objectif des portes ouvertes
c'est de faire découvrir ce que l'on
fait dans nos élevages dans nos fermes
parce que souvent là il ya plein de
personnes qui se posent à un petit peu
des questions ce que l'on a dans nos
dans nos grands bâtiments dans nos dans
nos terrains ce que l'on fait donc c'est
l'objectif c'est vraiment ça c'est de
faire découvrir et nous montrer ce que
l'on fait comment on produit les choses
et pourquoi on le fait de cette façon
par exemple pour les pour l'alimentation
des bovins pour des lamentations des
vaches et plein de gens qui se posent
des questions une manière complètement
légitime par rapport aux différentes
affaires qu'on a pu connaître
donc on explique simplement les choses